after months of back and forth EU
members have finally agreed on the
design of an artificial price ceiling
for natural gas purchases at least for
those purchases on Europe's primary
exchange where prices have skyrocketed
in recent months Brussels touts the
agreement as another sign of solidarity
experts wonder if it'll even work
EU members from eastern and southern
Europe got what they wanted a lower
level for the gas price Gap to kick in
at 180 Euros per megawatt hour that's
more than 100 euros lower than the
European commission initially proposed
and it's something the Netherlands
couldn't agree to with good reasons
critics say what the commission is doing
here is fiddling with the only energy
Market that is in Europe I mean it's the
only Commodities that we are trading in
Europe which is the ttf in the
Netherlands and so therefore the Dutch
are understood that Traders will move
away from the ttf and revert back to the
UK so I think what we've done today is a
massive gift to the UK because it's
going to be the main trading hub for gas
again the eo's gas price Gap will also
hurt Norway a major energy partner which
Brussels asked to increase gas volumes
to mitigate Russian Supply disruption
Norway won't welcome the idea of selling
gas at a lower price much like other
energy exporters it's going to have a
distorted impact plus it will perhaps
reduce security of Supply I mean we will
see Traders will soon try to test this
new cap to see what's happening many
fear producers will steer their gas
tankers to markets with higher prices
leaving the EU in the cold meanwhile
price cap supporters say the cap isn't
fixed and can be higher if supplies run
low
my colleague Aya Ibrahim joins me for
more out of Brussels Ayah we just heard
several reasons in that piece for why
this cap isn't a good idea why did the
EU then pursue this and ultimately agree
to it then
I think it's massive political pressure
from Eastern and Southern European
countries as that report has mentioned
who really have a fear that prices might
spiral completely out of control as we
have seen very high prices especially in
September and
um August I mean we have seen this since
the beginning of the you know Russia's
war on Ukraine and they really believe
that this will shield households and
consumers and that's why a compromise
had to be found on on this price cap
prices spiking at one point to 350 Euros
a megawatt hour on that Exchange in
August I believe it seems like a
no-brainer why was it so hard then for
Nations to agree on this cap what
exactly were the sticking points
I mean this what we have right now I
think it's more helpful to think of it
as a break or kind of Correction
mechanism that would kick in in case uh
the price reaches this 180 Euros that
you mentioned and it's a huge compromise
from what was initially proposed I mean
the initial price was around 275 uh
Euros instead of 180
um and there's also now the regulatory
bodies of the EU will actually have to
um have to now conduct an assessment to
see the veracity of the markets and if
the markets can really take
um
take this kind of Regulation and we are
told that if that assessment turns out
turns out or shows that there's too much
risk the assessment uh this pre the
price cap or this um a correction
mechanism might actually be Revisited so
it is it has come through a lot of
compromise and now member states feel
that there's enough uh security or
there's enough Clauses within this
agreement that could um that could allow
um you know a reversal because they fear
that this might actually just destroy
Supply and then the European Union would
end up with a whole other set of
problems on its hands that the the
supply of of this energy would just go
elsewhere to the to the highest bidder
if you will I you mentioned the pressure
coming from Southern and Eastern uh
European nations in particular on this
Brussels says hey this is a show of
solidarity that we passed this
um does this mean that these complicated
gas gas issues are now solved
essentially or is it going to remain
complicated for the for the coming years
months I mean we're in the middle of
winter
this is by no means a silver bullet nor
is this the end of I think the
discussion on this I mean and with
anything that is related to uh you know
dealing with the effects of the war in
Ukraine there's always that question of
solidarity between EU member states I
mean not everybody voted for this
yesterday I mean let's remember this
this decision did not require unanimity
we had um Austria and the Netherlands
abstaining and Hungary just voting
against it altogether so I expect bumps
ahead
all right I Ibrahim and Brussels thank
you